moving back to where was your mind that
led you to disappear to would you guys
go to vegas first and then tennessee no
i kind of refer to it as like the road
trip from hell
it's a very hunter s thompson way to
describe it right you went back to back
country maybe it was sort of hunter
thompson-esque except
without actual
drugs
um
that was one of the first questions my
father asked me was was it drugs and i
wished that i could have said yes yeah
because i didn't know how to explain
what had happened
um
but
so roshan took me away
involuntarily except you know of course
he wasn't holding a gun to my head but
all along it was like a metaphorical gun
was there ever physical abuse
um
no
what would qualify as sexual abuse yes
but physically
no
a couple of times we would get into
slightly physical fights but he never um
i mean he was
big and as
large and blubbery
as he was
he was he was also really strong so
sometimes he would like subdue me but
other than that no there wasn't physical
violence but a lot of people will say
that um
the psychological violence is
um
i don't want to diminish physical
violence but some people say that the
psychological and emotional violence is
more destructive
it's just that the physical violence is
easier to identify it's easier to
identify and and it seems kind of more
straightforward
whereas psychological you know and you
have a bruise on your face or you break
a bone and those things hopefully heal
in a visible way
but
psychological stuff
you know
you can't
easily identify or understand or others
can't easily identify it and then you
find yourself crying for no reason
at a beautiful song at some point yes
and it's that that has to do something
happening in the depth
of your mind okay so he took you away
but where was the i mean where was your
mind that was doing both of those things
was able to be taken away
but also was pushing to the the the
flourishing the reopening and the
flourishing of the restaurant well you
know i wouldn't have reopened the
restaurant with and then knowing i was
gonna all of a sudden be taken away from
it and it was gonna get closed again you
know it's like why why would i do that
why would anybody do that
um and
one of the things that i tried to do
towards the end was i was trying to get
myself off the bank accounts because i
didn't want him to be able to get money
out of me
and so there was uh one time when i
tried to get one of the investors we
went to the bank together to put her on
as the signer and take me off
and because we didn't have the operating
agreement they wouldn't let us do it so
it was like this little snafu
and um
so all of these things are
sort of the opposite of criminal intent
but that's a that's a legal thing what's
what's going on in your mind at this
time
i don't know i mean
well you always did you give yourself
a chance to just think
no and i think that's part of one of the
things that
might have
saved me or anybody that's pulled into a
cult one of the things that they do is
they keep you exhausted
overwhelmed confused and afraid
um
and so you don't have any time to think
so you're just kind of constantly
running and you're confused and then
things are happening that's funny
there's i have some quotes in my book
draft because i listen to a lot of
podcasts i don't know what the
logistics are of like crediting a quote
from a podcast in a book yeah but i have
a couple i think it was um
andrew huberman on
joe rogan said
something about um
if a animal if a human or animal i don't
know how he would know the human or
animal is stressed um
and i'm paraphrasing this horribly but
they're they're much more easily prone
to
um
be
not prone to but forced into delusional
thinking
um and so that quote resonated for me
because you know he kept me in this
incredibly stressed out afraid confused
state and then whatever he's sort of
planting in my mind i'm going to be that
much more likely to just kind of go
along with it well we'll see how this
whole journey
ends let's actually just step back a
little bit and just looking at the
employees at the restaurant and so on
do you have remorse for what happened
especially from the perspective of the
employees and the staff
yeah i mean hurting them was sort of the
last
thing that i would ever have wanted to
do
and
in part i mean there was
financial harm um
but i don't i don't know whether it's
more important or not but
you know it was
taking a place that
was very much like a family to them
um
and it was as if i destroyed it
and so i think that
because we were so much like a family it
was almost as if
like mom went off the deep end and
got together with some
cuckoo abusive guy and and sort of
abandoned them and they didn't know what
was going on and what was happening and
so do you regret lying to them
i regret lying to anybody
in all those circumstances but
i wasn't lying
you know
he made me think that you know
everything was going to be reversed and
okay and anybody that
money was borrowed from they would get
it back you know maybe tenfold and so it
was this weird situation of
having like one foot in his reality
and
potentially believing the things he was
saying or
even over time
wanting to believe them more and more
because the alternative was so um
the alternative was worse the
alternative was like
was increasingly a bigger and bigger
nightmare so so there's this whole
situation where you're constantly giving
them money you're constantly borrowing
borrowing money well this idea that'll
be repaid
like
100 x fold
right kind of like
so sort of like lying to somebody
because you're planning their surprise
party you think like well i'm lying to
somebody but um but it's because
there's a good reason
yeah you know it's sort of that's not a
good example but
but you could have
not made it a surprise party and be like
pull them in onto the planning of the
party
and be honest about
like everything that's happening not in
a negative way but like getting in on
the fact that okay i just need to
give money to this guy
but
we'll get
he is a super rich person of some kind
and he'll
um
repay
i mean i wish i well
because you're holding on to the first
time i mean that's part of the torture
is that you're isolated
and
unable
unable to tell anybody but you're not
unable or he was telling you you're not
allowed to say anything to anybody i
mean you're choosing not to say anything
but it's because of the sort of the
weight of it because it's embarrassing
to sort of
is it embarrassing it's something i mean
what why do you not tell others
you know
what what is that what's what what's
happening to the mind where you don't
tell others
i don't know you're part of why the
story you know everything that happened
is hard to
summarize and talk about
in any concise way is that
so much of it happens in this very slow
slow
slow way and
um
you know people always use the whole
like frog and boiling water example
um so that by the time you realize
you're [ __ ] it's too late
um
and it and it seems
hard to believe or understand to other
people because they see where you are or
where you ended up
and they think well how did you let that
happen and well i don't know
i would i have willingly destroyed my
life and hurt all the people i care
about and you know allowed my mother to
get hurt and
i wouldn't have ever ever willingly done
that so something else must have
happened and that's um
that's the part that's difficult to
understand
you